how is everything going
what no it's good we just don't sleep a
lot but three kids under five years old
I would imagine
now how old is Josiah now he will be six
months next week oh and once like I see
a little smile right there like what's
his latest Milestone oh eating probably
you started like Solitude and putting
things into his mouth yeah
um
yeah and sleeping ish sleeps when he
wants to occasionally occasionally we
had a really good night last night so
it's easy to be like oh he's so easy see
even though we have those nights that
it's not so easy but well he'll sleep
through the night tonight
and of course you have Jackson and Lila
Jackson does he love school how's that
going Jackson does yeah he likes school
a lot yeah
he likes playing with friends and I
think he likes the classroom environment
doing different things his school is
really cool too because it still has all
the like extracurriculars like like PE
and music and art and all those things
and he like thrives off stuff like that
so he's he's loving him and Lila what is
she into these days what is she loving
yeah she's her just it's been nice
having some one-on-one time when Jay is
at school with Lila like just being able
to spend some time alone with her
um she's all girl she loves all the
girly things and I was gonna say is she
mom's best friend because she's
outnumbered with the boys well no she's
definitely Daddy's girl oh my goodness
yes but but it's also she like she goes
back and forth I feel like though too
because she's also like we have our
Target run you know she loves shopping
but then she loves she loves her daddy
go go
well here we are with another new season
of the show season 24 which is wild to
think when you hear that number what
comes to mind it's a long time it's I
yeah TV longer
what 15 or 14 I've been doing TV longer
than I
wow I'm 32 now so that's
yeah longer than I have it and are the
kids Still Loving having the cameras
around I know Jackson loves a camera
moment yeah yeah they they they're okay
they uh yeah it depends on the day yeah
they're kids you know they like their
attention but then there's times when
you know they don't
um you know they want to beat their own
drum so uh I think they enjoy it overall
but um we love our crew they love our
crew and they make it nice and easy with
the kids what's so awesome too this
season we get to see baby number three
we get to see Josiah's birth and coming
into this world I mean to have that on
footage that you can look back at
whenever you want I mean how special is
that I'm pretty ready to get this kid
out of me Tori just went back
oh yeah it has been fun yeah all the
bursts all the yeah our wedding
um meet like our whole relationships on
camera yeah plus all of our kids
um
yeah all their birds so yeah it is kind
of special
um and yeah they've been right there
with it so
all the Milestones he was probably the
easiest with cameras I think we invited
cameras back the quickest oh yeah oh for
sure yeah so that's Jackson was like we
need all this time and by the third time
we were like yeah you're like whatever
get it going what else can we expect
with this new season a lot of this kitty
yeah a lot of Josiah a lot of Jackson
milestones so you know it's recovering
from his leg surgery he makes a you know
we have some of our dwarf friends come
over
um starts or he played soccer yeah
soccer at Alps played in d triple A so
which so I was I've played Detroit Blaze
my whole life so then Jackson did his
first d triple A event
um did your blood being dwarf Athletic
Association at the LPA conference so
um that was a big one your dad did say
that he thinks things are on the right
path you know we're definitely working
I'm talking to Zach every day would you
agree with that in terms of healing the
relationship between you two oh you know
I think a lot has happened it's going to
take a long time
um
you know I don't think responsibility
has you know has been taken so
but again we're just yeah we're we're
raising our family
um
I think it's presented a good
opportunity though for all of us to kind
of step back and just remember that
we're family and that's all that truly
matters and you know putting our
businesses and things aside for one
another I feel like the most important
thing yeah you've said before Tori that
the farm may not have felt like a place
of enjoyment for you at one point the
farm is not a place of joy for me
anymore do you still feel that way or
are things moving in a direction of
healing yeah no I mean it's it's sad I
feel like with everything that's hap
it's like a death in the family you know
like the farm has
for us I think it's like a like somebody
died and you know I think we've kind of
grieved that
process of letting it go and just moving
on and you know unfortunately I think
it's probably for me been tainted for
ever but you know we'll always have our
memories and nothing can change that
it's a very big complex deep
um
deep issue and a lot of things a lot of
history there so yeah having a show that
is so public facing having drama within
the family having social media trolls
all of that how do you make sure you
guys are protecting your mental health
within your family
uh I think doing what we did in a way
like
um
I think I'm relatively like
a healthy person but it is
um yeah just it's having to separate
from a situation that I didn't feel was
healthy for me I found myself getting
upset and
um I think as you become parents though
too like you you just your mindset
changes and not just with like all the
drama that's happened but with anything
you you make decisions based on your
family and no one else and that's what's
important your focus definitely changes
once you have kids yeah what would that
better situation have looked like what
would have been the ideal case I know we
can't go back to the past but would it
have been selling to you or keeping it
within the family I think just
communicating with all of us kids
at an earlier time the
um
yeah there's a lot there's a lot that's
a huge answer in my opinion
um
a lot of it some of it has to do with
the show something that has to do with
just family
um a lot of things I think should have
been done differently
um it's tough because yeah we put a lot
of our you know eggs in that basket but
it is what it is eventually I'd rather
cut that off now
um
and then if anything I feel like the
better thing happened like whatever you
know like you say that would have been
unfortunate to have gotten into a
situation that like in five years we're
like oh this isn't working because we
made decisions based off other people
but for like I think the first time in
our marriage we made a decision for our
family and did our own thing and it's
worked out yeah what would it take if
this is even something you would want to
mend that relationship with the rest of
the family or is it something right now
that you're just not you need time space
and want to focus on your own family
right here this yeah oh my gosh it's hot
but I've been
motivated for not just my dad but
re-engage
multiple parts of the family
multiple parts of the family re-engage
each other I think because anything else
seems
you know publicly
motivated and not you know privately
motivated do you feel like that would be
the next step for your family is to take
a step back I think so yeah I think take
a step back I think it's unfortunate but
things just weren't managed right am I
like I the list goes on for me this is I
I just don't know I don't know what else
to put it but yeah things were not
managed the farm wasn't managed right
and then relationships
right and um
I'm a patriarch guy I think that's the
right word but like family parents you
know they got the siblings you know it
starts at the top responsibility
um and all that so that in my opinion
failed and now we're in the situation
we're in so I'm gonna make my new
Mountain over here and that's that's
just how it is so
so what will the holidays look like
we're still family so the holiday we'll
probably see them yeah we'll see the
family like everyone wants to see the
babies and the grandkids so we'll
probably see each other but it's I I
always like equate it to like though
it's like normal to only see your family
at like birthdays and Christmas like
that's like no you don't always have to
be best friends with each other and you
know I think for right now that's just
like the healthy thing to do yeah and
you know we're all still there for each
other no matter what happens at the drop
of the Hat totally we'll still all see
each other at holidays yeah and like we
have Tori's side of the family too like
well see each other but it I do have
family in there sometimes yeah like yeah
you're just a little off but you know
there's another side for the family
to know have the cameras step aside but
you have
helped so many people through the years
and and really truly congratulations on
the success of the show and and what
you've been able to accomplish using
your platform that that must mean
something to you must be proud of that
yeah no definitely and it's unfortunate
maybe this you know maybe a little
tainted but yeah no I know I've
we've inspired
um a lot of people
um and that yeah will never be taken
away so it's definitely been a a journey
and a lot of positives along the way but
um yeah I like still remember when I
first like came into like started dating
Zach and met him and things like that
like I still remember seeing people meet
him and his family and you know like
I always told them like you guys have
the opportunity to like make someone's
day like when you say hi to somebody or
have like even a 30 second conversation
people are just like elated by the time
that they leave that conversation and
totally and for what I think our show's
done for the dwarf Community too um
it's made people aware of dwarfism I
meant where but also like inspiring I a
lot of like for me it's the young boys
young teen kids that are like wow you
got married you had kids that's all
possible you can have a family so yeah
that's definitely been you know a
highlight of my life
[Music]
foreign